I'm not actually that nervous so I'm
gonna be cutting Jennifer's hair today I
would like snip right there a lot on
going see already I could see you're
getting really angry at me
you better not she doesn't want me to do
that new girl look new cut new girl new
life she has a lot of hair
we're gonna bring it back I think you're
gonna be surprised hopefully but I do
have a hair point
Justin Tings
I feel like I'm constructing an IKEA set
right now so that means I'm gonna look
awful I feel like a more Project Runway
right now they don't cut their hair in
Project Runway okay another one I felt
like a lot knock in if you ponytail it
and cut it I'll kill you okay I know
baby I'm sorry I never went to
haircutting school I would advise you to
look at my front and make sure that two
sides are the same like the same length
okay there's no awkward strand like the
ones that I'm feeling in for now okay
should I do it all in one like all in
one is that the right way to do it
no just like that you go below yeah like
this
yeah I think just cut myself there no
nothing looks cute yeah yeah you good
baby this is pretty hard
okay I may not be even everywhere
all right not good it doesn't look bad
actually it looks pretty good right it
doesn't look like Jennifer Aniston at
all but one of those scary monster dolls
that you might hit Toys R Us it looks
like a trim your highness yours is a
little shorter I think it's good I like
the bang look it's a bang instead of
bangs you got going on there so you
could look at this it's like in and down
that's really the problem I thought it
would be worse I mean there's I can live
with it see not terrible that's always
going for you look cute I know yikes
you need trust for something like this I
definitely have a little bit more
respect for hair stylist
me too
she's still pretty cute mm-hmm
you've got hair all over you by the way